what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from new rock
star spider-man no way home trailer toby
at andrew removals confirmed from within
the trailer sorry for sighted a little
bit sort of throaty and congested that's
just the way it is today guys but hey i
wanted to do a quick reminder epic
heroshop.com where i got this vision
inspired shirt you got that loki shirt i
got a green one with that we also got an
awesome mobius and mobius shirt
basically our most comfortable
marvel shirts and coolest looking marvel
shirts epic heroshop.com where you've
probably heard is in association with
new rockstars they're having a special
sale monday november 22nd through the
29th 15
off at minimum and they're bringing back
some designs as well you best bet that
we already are planning on buying a good
amount you'll be seeing us rock a lot of
epic hero shop throughout
the rest of the year
and next year because the year's almost
over anywho let's watch this
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and spider-man no way home's newest
trailer confirms a bit about this movie
surprise cameos but in one big case an
even bigger secret completely by
accident it looks like by now you may
have seen a brazilian version of the
trailer in which as electro sandman and
the lizard leap across the scaffolding
towards spider-man in the movie's
apparent final battle blizzard dives
like he's in a world cup semi-final yeah
it's a bizarre ring
so many times by some invisible object
that can only be explained by ant-man by
papa feige sniping him for spoilers or
most likely the presence of andrew
garfield spider-man and toby maguire
spider-man in this shot but scrubbed
from the trailer footage are you sure
about that and his name is john cena
it makes sense three versus three would
be much better composition than one
versus three lizard is clearly jumping
towards something in a different spot
than tom holland's peter parker is i
mean that's the thing about this shot
right away is that even if he didn't see
the brazil one with the weird head
contortion moment from lizard you get so
swept up in the shot of seeing
spider-man charging after electro
sandman and lizard but when you take a
second to just look at the shot alone
even without the head movement it's a
weird shot where are they all charging
towards and lizards doesn't even look
like he's looking up at spider-man or
aiming towards him so clearly
something's removed even prior to the
whole it's already kind of a strange
shot when you think about it yeah and
what's peter jumping towards exactly
other than just kind of all of it yeah
just i better go hit sandman let's try
it yeah i'm pretty sure i found even
more visual evidence that more things
were removed from this moment of the
trailer so toby and andrew's existence
in this movie while still not confirmed
by the filmmakers it's just a foregone
conclusion in the minds of those fans so
at this point i am honestly less excited
by their mere possible presence in this
film than i now am by why they are
actually in this movie and what that
tells us about the broadening multiverse
going forward but let's start with a
closer look at the shot in question
peter leaps from the head of the statue
of liberty toward electro sandman and
lizard who attacked from the surrounding
scaffolding peter seems to be aiming
directly for sandman while sandman hooks
his fist around from peter's left which
tracks with the next shot
but not only does the lizard recoil from
some invisible hit in the brazilian
trailer lizard is lined up to strike
someone in a completely different spot
than peter is but also so is electro go
through this frame by creating the
electro is also pulling back his arm for
a strike against someone who is above
where peter is and then
dude you can see electro still above
continuing to engage someone else with
an electric
wow
man i gotta give credit man i didn't
even notice anything about electro
pulling us our back and charging clearly
the evidence is right there because we
all got so focused on lizard and it's
pretty obvious that spidey's headed
towards sad bad but the whole thing with
electro all that just flew over my head
honestly i didn't even pay attention to
it yeah and him above too attacking
somebody who's not the peter in the
foreground coming towards us now i just
wonder why toby maguire would be
fighting that electro other than
circumstance i don't know i mean it's
probably more personal for andrew to go
after lizard considering the
relationship that formed in amazing
spider-man and we already had toby
fighting against sandman and we haven't
had toby fight against electro yet but
also inside the trailer this could just
be manipulation for the trailer looked
like electro was fighting doc ock
so maybe um donkoff is back on toby's
side so that's why he's going after
electro goodbye
in the shot of peter leaping off the
statue of liberty head if you look to
the region to the right of peter there
is definitely an upward moving smokey
motion blur on the background rim of
that giant cap shield as if something
was here leaving out a frame removed and
when they had to pencil back and what
was behind it some of the motion blur
stayed also this one's a bit harder to
see but over on the left side of the
same shot a similar motion blur seems to
be distorting the tip of lady
before tom holland peter parker does now
i thought this was just digital noise
but the distortion does not appear on
any other regions of the frame or on the
shot before this of peter landing on the
statue head which you'll notice does cut
to black as if to mask two other figures
landed on either side of peter right
after he lands who would then leap off
right before he leaps i mean yeah i
think you're right about that i mean if
you just even look at the shot the
visual language yeah the visual language
of where the shot is of where he's
landing it's a perfect it would be
perfect symmetry for one to be over
there and another one to be over there
oh that's dude
i hope he's right i hope he's right
i really hope he's right now when you go
back to the wide collision shot
everything in frame is moving with
debris lightning sand you can't really
discern any extraordinary motion blur
except there is a subtle
odd downward sweep of sandman sand in
the bottom of the frame like someone
wafted it downward in that blank region
that the lizard is approaching now
there's also this random detail a lot of
you keep asking me about this brown
shape that's hanging from the
scaffolding to the left of ned as mj
falls some say this could be an arm of
some peter parker that wasn't fully
erased to be honest i don't see how this
is an arm it looks like a bundle of rope
to me and like if a vfx artist goes to
the effort to erase it yeah i can see
that get tired halfway through and then
decide to re-color it brown so i don't
know what this is i just don't think
it's another spider-man though yeah we
did we were one of the people who said
that during your breakdown
where's your where is
how you talk about this i don't know i
mean i guess a bundle of rope but it
definitely looks like they tried
compositing out stuff from it doesn't it
like what's the space in between right
here what's this space it's just a rope
that's like how is it hanging up looks
like there's still something grabbing on
to something here i mean yeah it looks
like at the bottom it comes into finger
points or something like that like now
these pointed it out it kind of looks
like a rope but then yeah the bit above
it that's on the little you know
clasp point like that can't tell what
that would be i'm torn now because i'm
like yeah i mean it seems like it would
be a pretty glaring thing for an
animator to be like i got most of the
way there let me just paint over this
brown and call it a day but i think also
contextually that was also the thing i
was making fun of a lot during our live
stream is if it is an art why would that
spider-man just be chilling there while
this situation with ned and mj going
over the railing is going on yeah i was
like why wouldn't you care
because story-wise it makes no sense why
that spider-man's not doing anything and
just from an editing standpoint i could
tell from the audio that that audio that
this is an insert that you had to do
later in post after filming the original
video for this i'm just pointing that
out i noticed these things don't think
it's another spider-man though now two
months ago after andrew garfield
discussed some rumored set leaks from no
way home on the tonight show would you
mean fallon we here at new rockstars did
a vfx analysis on some online claims
over whether or not the set footage of
garfield was doctored now i won't show
that full footage here but i will tell
you it does seem to match the
scaffolding that surrounds the statue of
liberty
trailer but beyond the visuals of this
scene there are some contextual clues in
the trailer that help us understand why
toby and andrew would even show up in
this movie obviously mj falls from the
scaffolding in slow motion that closely
mirrors gwen stacy's death drop in the
amazing spider-man 2. and while the
trailer very clearly makes it seem like
it's tom holland in his new spidey suit
reaching out for mj here it also does
read like a chance for andrew garfield
to redeem himself by saving mj and if
they can shrub and swap out other stuff
in this trailer it's not too hard to
imagine a different spider-man hand
reaching down in the theatrical version
also there's a line where doc ock sees
tom holland's face and says you're not
peter parker reminding us that some toby
maguire peter parker exists somewhere in
this merged spider verse also peter
mentions his spider bite to mj not that
big of a deal but it is something that
has only come up once in the mcu before
this this line could be setting up this
peter finally detailing his superhero
origin in no way home which could come
in the form of a conversation with other
peter parkers whose varying bites uncle
ben deaths and web shooting abilities
are something we are all eager for them
to compare notes on i want them to
compare notes on who had the worst death
with uncle ben that's why that's my
mother that's the main thing i want them
to talk about is uncle ben it'd be nice
to get tom holland to actually speak
about it even at the event that he did
with coy he did say one less that i hope
that audiences have a takeaway with w as
his portrayal of spider-man is with
great power comes great responsibility
i'm like you're quoting the uncle bad
maybe you will actually talk about uncle
ben this time around i mean it would be
such a touching scene to have all three
of them meet on that point and you know
share that together or at least talk
about it a little bit ultimately i think
this could tell us why alternate peters
could be so important to crossover into
the mcu not just to blow our minds it's
gonna do that but peter needs to learn
from other versions of himself that it
is impossible to have it all something
toby maguire peter learned in his movies
and that sometimes you might be unable
to save someone you love which andrew
garfield peter parker learned in his
movie i mean the fact that this battle
restages gwen stacy's death drop with mj
hints that a key mechanism for andrew
and toby's returns will be to give these
past peter parkers one last chance to
redeem their biggest mistakes for andrew
peter that was letting gwen die
obviously and for toby peter that was
letting his mentors die lying to his
best friend letting vengeance open him
up to toxic influences and turning his
mary jane against him while in jail
they don't kiss they don't get engaged
it's really a muddy we're still working
through this kind of ending one of the
reasons i think sam raimi spider-man 3
is super under-appreciated and a
potential mixed bag of a future for that
version of peter parker that this movie
could revisit like imagine toby mcguire
peter parker never truly fixed things
with mj and he now counsels tom holland
peter parker a younger peter to just
retire early enjoy a normal college life
despite that pretty crappy advice mr
stark gave you in civil war when bad
things happen they don't always happen
because of you kid you deserve your own
life
i don't think toby is going to be
telling him that especially because toto
maguire is clearly going to be in a
spider-man outfit
and his age
[Laughter]
older than tom holland just saying
retire early you're a hypocrite yeah
yeah absolutely
take it from me who's i'm still doing it
don't do it unless i want to ruin a
legacy character me like yeah i'm still
spider-man it sucks i don't have married
jade anymore i feel like it would have
to be a difference and he would have to
give him some kind of advice on the
ballot that the core spider-man conflict
how to balance the two not just and you
know give it up like spider-man 2. so
while many of us are expecting to hear
the line with great power comes great
responsibility and no way home it
wouldn't surprise me to hear tobey
maguire peter parker offer a more
evolved take on that famous adage that
only an experienced spider-man could
speak with authority on oh i have it
just for you i know exactly what he's
gonna say what toby is gonna say a more
enhanced version just like you were
saying is you were a lot like your
father you really are peter and that's a
good thing but your father by a
philosophy a principal really he
believed that if you could do good
things for other people you had a moral
obligation to do those things that's
what's at stake here not choice
responsibility and then andrew's going
to be like you know i remember my uncle
ben once said that to me but i was just
kind of rephrasing my head going you
know you could have made this shorter
which is saying with great power comes
great responsibility
our greatest responsibility is knowing
when to give up that power so this idea
of learning from the past one universe
building on the knowledge gained from
other universes i think that's going to
be the driving theme as the mcu expands
into a multiverse of cooperative
cross-universe team-ups like the
spider-verse like the captain britain
core like the fantastic four arguably
what kang has already accomplished with
the council of kangs you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow me rockstar
subscribers
for more analysis and breakdowns
spiderman related thanks for watching
bye
i hope one lesson that they all learn
from each other from learning from the
past is guys we shouldn't introduce so
many main characters and so many
villains in one spider-man movie
never learn that lesson
ever but that's what they say to each
other in this film it's crowded isn't it
it sure is it is
i've been there me too my past in my
universe we also had a lot of main
characters and villains and people
thought it was overpopulated that's
going to work out great here it's
another weird feeling i feel like it's
just going to click here all right guys
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button check out epic hero shop.com next
week we'll catch you guys
soon you